we have every reason to be horrified at
the prospect of Donald Trump in the
White House but I don't think people
should fool themselves into thinking
that they should sleep well at night
with Hillary Clinton in the White House
either they're both dangerous and
unacceptable in different ways this is
why we should be rejecting this
political system that serves the very
few and the very powerful
the 2016 presidential race features two
of the most disliked candidates in
electoral history which has given a
boost not only to the libertarian
party's Gary Johnson but to Jill Stein a
66 year old harvard-trained physician
from Massachusetts
who's running on the Green Party ticket
Stein is currently polling at about 2
percent trailing Gary Johnson who's on
track to take about four percent of the
popular vote Stein who sat down last
week for an interview with reason says
this election year presents an historic
opportunity for third parties this is a
realignment election the Democrats have
split in two with their sabotage of
Bernie's campaign and the principle you
know burners have come into our campaign
right which is you know really been the
source of a big revival in the Green
Party so it's a realignment and you have
this marriage of the Democratic and
Republican parties now it's really
important I think for greens and
libertarians to be working together
right now to just break through this
stranglehold and challenging them right
out of the game vote for your Johnson or
Jill Stein is a vote for Donald Trump is
just how it is as the race is tightened
in these last couple weeks the calls to
third-party supporters to hold their
noses and cast the vote for Hillary have
intensified such as this video plea from
Hollywood screenwriters Joss Whedon we
want to have more choices that we need
to start working on that after the
election these concerns trace back to
the year 2000 when then Green Party
candidate Ralph Nader was blamed for
drawing enough votes from Al Gore with
George W Bush and the White House Al
Gore didn't win his home state had he
won his home state Florida would not
have been an issue you know they really
tried to redirect this and blame it on
the greens we're in a very different
moment from 2000 regardless because most
people have now rejected this political
system it's almost 60 percent of people
that are clamoring for a new independent
political party yeah so we are in that
moment we're in a breakthrough moment
the only question is when is a
happen stein says that if only the US
were to adopt a new system of voting
Americans wouldn't have to make this
choice between voting their conscience
or the lesser of two evils we could
solve this problem of this voting system
based on fear we could solve it and you
know that with a stroke of a pen with a
system called rank-choice voting it lets
you rank your choices so if your first
choice loses your vote is automatically
reassigned to your second choice that
way you can vote for the underdog that
you favor the ranked choice voting is on
the ballot in Maine this year so it is
not something you are behind yes
absolutely and here's another
interesting thing it's on the ballot by
voter referendum which is the only way
that it has ever moved forward right
because it is a threat to establishment
politics none other than Jerry Brown the
Democratic governor of mass of
California just vetoed a ranked choice
voting law that would have made it
available to all cities and towns in
California he just struck it down you
know because they're scared to death
Stein in the libertarian Gary Johnson
have a lot in common on topics like
foreign policy marijuana legalization
and same-sex marriage but an economic
issues the two candidates couldn't be
farther apart I think the difference
between you know maybe the libertarian
terminology and the green terminology is
that we're not striving for government
we're striving for We the People and for
decentralized public control free of
corporate influence it seems to me that
we the people is kind of a nice gloss on
government right right absolutely and it
cannot be allowed to you know to just go
off on its own it requires constant
scrutiny constant transparency and
constant accountability
what's the Green Party plan to pay for
all these programs so first let me say
health care as a human right that pays
for itself in fact it actually won't
cost taxpayers any more what we're doing
is redirecting that same volume of money
which is going into paper-pushing and
also into this captured market Stein
says she poor federal money into the
clean energy sector and end our use of
fossil fuels by the year 2030 the green
New Deal actually pays for itself so you
we put money in to jumpstart it but it
actually has repaid that money within a
decade and a half because we get so much
healthier by creating a healthy food
system rather than the the subsidized
sick food that we have right now she
also believes in free college tuition
for all which she claims would actually
make money for taxpayers turns out for
every dollar we put in to higher
education we get back seven dollars in
return and improve revenues and public
benefits so it pays for itself yep you
got a prime the pump
and it's about a hundred billion dollars
to prime that pump is the national debt
something that you think is legitimate
to be concerned about and do you
advocate actually cutting back any
government programs or you know
reforming entitlements means testing to
reduce government spending to bring that
under control so here's what history
tells us about that yeah the way you
actually get out of debt is by
judiciously investing in the productive
economy so our productive economy
basically went overseas we need to
restart that productive economy that's
what the green New Deal does it provides
those strategic investments what gives
you faith that the federal government
could properly invest money in sectors
that that are gonna grow because we've
seen in the past malinvestment you know
the the Solyndra bust was famously a bad
solar investment the shovel-ready jobs
Obama invested in for the stimulus
weren't exactly shovel ready here in
California we have a huge boondoggle
called the high-speed rail
seems to be going nowhere just by you
know a huge price tag so what you know
so I have some skepticism about the
ability of governments to jumpstart the
economy with investment what gives you
faith that that can actually work yeah
so we have a very corrupted government
yes you know in which lobbyists and the
revolving door rule today so the green
New Deal is protected first of all it's
not a federal cookie cutter program okay
so it provides resources incentives
low-interest loans etc at the local
level so and there it calls for a
process that's firewalled from the
pay-to-play
so if you're part of the pay-to-play
system you cannot participate if you are
providing campaign contributions and
you've got a lobbyist that's that's got
a stake in this then you have basically
exited yourself from participating in
the process so that it's people in the
community coming together to say we need
this kind of stuff mm-hmm to meet the
criteria which is basically making a
more sustainable community in terms of
food energy public transit etc so this
is a decentralized process Stein has
been battling the perception that the
Green Party is anti-vaccine after she
told The Washington Post that there were
real questions that needed to be
addressed I think some of them at least
have been addressed I don't know if all
of them have been addressed in regards
to small amounts of mercury once found
in childhood vaccines despite a
scientific consensus that there's never
been a link between vaccines and autism
or any other serious health problems I
think that's the the birther issue of
2016 that is it's it's a concocted issue
okay because I know certainly the stuff
that's gotten thrown at me is ridiculous
I am very much supportive of vaccines as
an infrastructure of Public Health and
you're a medical doctor I'm a medical
doctor yes I get vaccines myself my kids
got vaccinated you know I I come from a
family of doctors and you know that's
just nonsense on the other hand I've
taken on the FDA
for being a you know a revolving door
for pharmaceutical companies and for
GMOs and that's my objection and you
know and so I think there's a little bit
of smoke screening going on here that
tries to translate my watchdogging of
our our regulatory institutions which
are far too much under the influence
with the election just days away
both Johnson and Stein's poll numbers
are slipping one meaningful benchmark
for both parties would be to win five
percent of the popular vote that would
lead the Federal Election Commission to
confer the classification of minor party
which means they'd have an easier time
getting ballot access and be eligible
for matching public funds what would
success or failure look like for the
Green Party this year in my view we've
already succeeded beyond our wildest
dreams for what happened in the Sanders
campaign and what it revealed about the
Democratic Party I think it's only fear
that constrains principled people now to
vote to vote Democrat I think the
Democrats that really cast their own
seeds of destruction right now this is
why we should be rejecting this
political system that serves the very
few and the very powerful it's
outrageous that people should be
struggling right now with this question
of do I prefer a fascist or or a
warmonger